-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy Award-winning acto
you know from hit shows
like "Cheers,"
"Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
and "The Good Place."
He stars in "Mr. Mayor,"
which airs Thursday nights
at 8:00 p.m. here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Now, I know
a bunch of you independent
thinkers wouldn't -- [ Scoff ]
wouldn't even wear masks,
but what about helmets?
It's simple.
Download our free
helmet-sharing app, Safe LA.
Use the map feature
to locate a helmet.
Now, you're ready to enter
the unique 14-digit code
that, uh, releases
the helmet security cover.
You then have 20 seconds to --
Are you kidding me?
Couldn't we just them
in a bin or something?
-[ Laughing ] I don't know
-Okay. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show
one of the best, Ted Danson.
How are you, Ted?
-I'm great.
How are you?
Nice to see your face.
-It's nice to see
your face, too.
Are you in a sitcom kitchen,
right now,
or your personal kitchen?
-It's a new-build rental
up in Vancouver,
so it is very similar
-[ Laughing ]
-to a sitcom kitchen.
-That's right, now,
you were in Vancouver,
I should say,
with your lovely bride,
Mary Steenburgen.
And you guys seem to work ou
your schedule very well,
that you are not shooting
at the same time that often.
-Yeah. You know, you would think
that it'd be more fun
to work at the same time
and then be able to go off
on this wonderful vacation
together, but, truth is,
especially nowadays,
it's nice to have one of us home
to catch the other.
You know,
cook and do housekeeping
and all that stuff,
which I'm actually
really good at.
-You're good at housekeeping
in general?
-Yeah. Yeah.
I have no idea why.
My dad used to do it.
I find it very satisfying
to make something dirty, clean
-So this is not --
By the way,
you know my wife, Alexi.
This is very much a qualit
she has that I don't have.
But you're claiming
this is something
that's always been true of you
-Yes. Yes.
Before I had a -- [ Laughs ]
before I could afford
a vacuum cleaner,
I would go around on my hand
and knees, picking up, you know,
lint and little pieces
of something from the carpet
-[ Laughing ]
-This is really kind of sad.
Can we change the subject?
-No. I'm just happy you finall
got that vacuum money.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, so, I'm also happy,
you know,
"The Good Place"
ended this wonderful run,
tied a bow on a fantastic show
And I think myself,
everybody in the industry,
was very worried
that you were not going
to land on your feet and, yet...
-[ Laughing ]
here you are, right away,
doing another sitcom.
How quickly
after "The Good Place"
were you aware of this project
and the fact
that you would be doing it
-Actually,
before we finished shootin
because Mike Schur, our creator,
knew, before the season started,
that this would be the las
season of "The Good Place.
So he let us all know,
so we really had, you know
five or six months
of preparation,
of being able to say goodbye
and also move on.
-Mike Schur, who I got to know
working with him at "SNL,"
and now, of course,
you're working with Tina Fey
and Robert Carlock,
who I knew the same way.
They're all friends with Mike,
vice versa,
but "Mr. Mayor" is a very
different kind of show,
don't you think?
-Yes. Yes.
It's a lot sillier
and, boy, do we go fast.
You know, I kind of grew u
in the "Cheers"
"Here's a joke.
Really funny, wasn't it?
-[ Laughing ]
-Great. Let's have a laugh
Okay, we're going
to move on now," you know.
And this is like
you just tear through the joke
and, you know, buckle up.
You can always rewind it,
if you want, and check it out,
but they don't stop
for the laugh, so.
Yeah, at 73, I'm having to learn
how to speak quickly.
-Well, it's interesting
because, you know,
the main difference, of course
is that, "Cheers,"
there was a live studio audience
that was reacting
to very funny jokes.
As somebody
who watched "Cheers,"
I greatly appreciated watching
you all in the laughter,
but, especially
on a show like "Cheers,"
it must've been weird,
figuring out what to do
while the audience was laughing.
I read -- and please
tell me this is true,
because it made me very happy --
that you also didn't know
what to do, as an actor,
and they gave you a note
on what to do while the
audience was laughing.
-Yes. It started out,
"Just eat a peanut.
Just say your joke,
eat a peanut."
And then, we found out
that wasn't funny,
so we moved to pretzels.
[ Laughing ]
Ate a lot of pretzels.
You know, it's funny,
but you do need,
with a live audience,
you do need that, in case
your joke isn't that funny
and you thought it might be,
you do need that thing to go to,
so you don't just go...
you know?
"Oh, no. It wasn't funny."
[ Laughter ]
-That's --
I mean, I was going to say
what an interesting thing,
I would love to experience it,
but you might know I used to
do this show with an audience.
So I'm kind of finding out
in real time what it's lik
to go from a "Cheers"
to a Carlock/Fey project.
-Ah, it's -- it's crazy.
And now with COVID, they're --
before -- we started --
it took us a year
to shoot nine episodes
because of this
doggone pandemic.
It started out
that they were on the floor,
you know,
in Video Village watching,
and you could go around
the corner,
and you could see
that they were enjoying it
or it was funny or
it needed work or whatever
And then,
we had the nine-month hiatus
because of COVID, the shutdown
and when we came back,
things were vastly different
They were in New York on a
computer screen Zooming with us,
and we had masks and shields
So you'd come up --
You know, "Is that Tina?
I guess so."
-[ Laughs ]
-"She's giving me a note,
and I'm don't -- like, okay.
You know, it was not as much
fun, I'll have to admit.
-One thing, though,
that Bobby spoke about
and I actually moderated a panel
with you and the cast,
and it seems to be true
is that because you had
this very long gap
from shooting the pilot
to going back to work
and then another gap
from when you started shooting
the first episodes until now
you did get very close
as a cast.
That must be nice.
-It was.
It was very nice.
I think the first three
episodes --
I know I was just,
"Can I do this?
What am I doing?
Learn your lines."
And then we had
that nine months,
and it was, I mean, obviousl
so intensely scary, disturbing
all those things, the shut-ins
that we started to Zoom
with each other
just for no reason
and catch up with each other
And you kind of really
learn some --
You know, probably you had
a deeper cut
at who these people were
if you hadn't done it.
We went through
Black Lives Matters,
and we went through so
many different phases
of this astounding, you know
time that we're living in
that by the time we came back,
we were much closer.
Yeah.
I really love these people
-It's a --
It's a wonderful cast.
Ted, one of the prices
of being as excellent
for as long as you have been
is that it's impossible for yo
now to be a revelation, right?
Nobody is watching a show, being
like, "You know who is funny
Ted Danson."
You've established that.
Holly Hunter
is kind of a revelation.
She's so wonderful in the show
I mean, I've seen her
be funny before,
but to see her be funny
on TV like this
is just such a delight.
-Yeah, she's -- she's intens
in this wonderful way.
You know how when you play
tennis with somebody
and if they're better than you
your game comes up?
Man, she hits the tennis bal
back so fast, it is incredible
And she's ferocious
and relentless, and --
Yeah, I'm really tickled
to be able to work with he
because I love her and hav
loved her acting for so long
And then, speaking of -- I don't
know if it's a revelation.
We've always known
that Bobby Moynihan
is -- is just
out-of-the-gate funny,
but oh, my God,
he's wonderful on our show
-It's really --
It makes me genuinely happ
knowing you both personall
and what nice people you are
It makes me genuinely happ
to see you guys working together
because you're great together.
-Yeah.
He is just the sweetest,
kindest, happiest daddy.
You know, he's incredible.
-I should note you are playing
the mayor of Los Angeles.
It's a fictional mayor.
It's not based on anybody.
But it does seem nice to,
in this day and age,
show people that anyone
can be an elected official
because that really strikes me
as what your character is.
-Yeah. No, I am that 73-year-old
very white, very rich guy
who should not
be still in the game.
He should be irrelevant
and somehow lucks into it.
And there's this great lin
that's actually true
where my staff is saying,
"Don't tell him,
but the truth is that
he got 67% of the vote,
but only 18% of Los Angele
votes in the mayoral elections
on an off year,
if it's not a presidential
election."
So I -- You know,
I got 8%, maybe, of the vote
So -- And that's true.
That's literally what happens.
-Well, you're both --
your character's both
incredibly underqualified,
but I still think
you're better than most.
And it is always just
such a delight to see you, Ted
Thanks so much for making time
for us today.
-Thanks for talking
about the show.
Much love to everybody.
-And Mary did ask me to tell you
it's time to start cleaning up
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. Mayor" airs Thursday nights
at 8:00 right here on NBC.